So, it’s a bit of a weird time to be celebrating anything
but we just passed 8 million subscribers.
I can’t believe there’s 8 million of you out there!
The Vox video team is lucky to be safely working from home right now.
We’re so grateful to the people
who keep the world running every day.
But also we’re really lucky that you’re out there
and we know from the comments that people who watch these videos
are as curious, and surprising, and funny
as any audience that we could hope for.
We’re sharing a few things that have brought joy while we’ve been working from home the past few weeks.
Because we could all use some of that.
Because it is spring...
this little bird nest, on this swing, has a little egg in it.
That's crazy!
A bunch of old pictures of myself with my family.
And I’ve been taking some time to scan all of them, just try to restore them, make them look a lot less dated.
Like this one for example, it’s just cool seeing them in better condition.
Hello and welcome to my kitchen.
Right now in New York City, we can’t eat in restaurants unfortunately.
But it has given me an opportunity to cook a lot more and it’s something that’s really comforting for me.
For me, that’s been coming to this park near my house next to San Fransisco Bay.
And you get pretty amazing views of San Francisco which is where our office is based.
But anyway, hoping to get back into the city at some point in the near future.
Something that brings me joy in my neighborhood is this park.
That’s my baby.
Baking brings my roommate joy and eating brings me joy.
So far we have had focaccia, and challah, and scallion pancakes.
That’s bread.
And now, bagels!
Which, um… they’re pretty good! They’re really good. They’re really good.
I’m out for a run and these guys are bringing me a lot of joy today.
I love this game, it’s called Lux.
It’s basically a computerized version of Risk.
I’ve felt pride as I've concurred my enemies.
So I recommend Lux, if you want to escape reality by… destroying your close friends.
I’ll do one more that’s less negative. Um.
One of my joys have been... just buying random stuff off of eBay.
Because quality is important.
But quantity is key when you’re stressed.
Definitely been re-reading some books we already have.
This one’s called Severance by Ling Ma and it’s great.
It’s actually about a virus in the United States.
So, it might hit a little too close to home - but it’s great.
Thor just looks the best on camera.
It’s too much Flash.
Those are head bites. Those are just weird head bites.
I’m working from home with a 2-year-old who is a constant source of joy.
This is what working from home with a 2-year-old basically looks like.
Here, here, here!
So I’m in a lockdown in Delhi, and the thing that’s making me the absolute happiest are my nieces.
Oh my god, 8 million?
Finding small excuses to change out of my sweatpants.
I’ve been scheduling the occasional, fancy, Zoom cocktail hours with some friends.
Calls with my grandmother.
Hi, I was on the porch and I forgot to take the phone out there with me.
No worries! Hi, how are you?
One thing that gives me joy is my partner’s garden here.
I just really have so much joy in having this... being able to see life happen in this tiny New York apartment.
For me, that means playing the piano
and re-painting all the rooms in my house.
There are a few things that do bring me joy.
One of them being my dog so we could still take him for walks,
and being able to get to my favorite hiking spot the other day.
Right now, normally my family and I celebrate Ramadan.
And my mom is here stateside with us.
But she’s unable to be because most flights are suspended.
So she’s transported her cooking here through FaceTime
and I’ve been cooking the recipes that she would normally cook if she was here.
So here we go - here’s the final product.
Here’s the tagine. Here’s the harira.
And here’s... A last surprise for you guys.
Yeah, to be honest, a lot went wrong with this cake.
But, just wanted to say we love you from Vox.
On days when I need a little fresh air and a little joy...
I go up to my roof.
Another thing that’s been bringing me a lot of joy is this sound at 7pm.
Can you hear that?
Thank you nurses and doctors!
And those are all the people clapping.
And that brings me joy!
Thank you so much for watching - as always.
Thank you for watching!
Mwah!
Bye!